肇社長が3億円の心境買って早1ヶ月が
経った
大量の与儀棒
まるで使われていないキッチン
後輩がタバコ吸いそうなベランダ
無駄に広い庭
バーベキューしたいベランダ
ちょっと照明暗めの廊下
めっちゃ男が好きそうなロマンあふれるあ
復興 al エレベーターフォアれてます
エレベータファーレます部屋
廊下肇社長の3県の5.2何があったの
だろうか
[音楽]
てっ
難しいから中で太郎
[音楽]
本日は肇社長です
というわけで最初にもあった通りですね
佐賀を系の号米を買ったもののまだま等に
行ったことがありませんこの弓枝
買いましたが私私餌を経営するお家を買い
ました見ても美しい照明の数々お部屋も前
の動画で紹介したんですけどもい何今谷
この家に進めていないという現実がこれ
なぜかと言いますとちんこれなぜかと言い
ますとこの家
自分で全部しなきゃいけないんですよ今
賃貸家賃を払ってお部屋に済ませて
いただいていたんですけどもこの日は違う
便器つい動画んすこの周辺の掃除とか
草むしりとかも含めてすべてすべて自分で
やるべきだとネットが通ってない次節
ユーチューバーにとってネットがとってい
ないってもほぼ住めないに等しいんで超
時期かなり
国庫にしっかりするのは時間かかると思わ
れていますあのショットあの忙しい
アピールしたくないんですけど忙しいん
ですよ相当忙しくて最近なとも静岡に入れ
た時間がなくて
dare to
ぼっちが管理する図鑑なんかはだけでは
ない僕人も近くの管理ができませんた億円
のユニを進めません6位までありがとう
ございました
になるわけないじゃないですかってなる
わけないじゃないですかねぇこんな素敵な
言えばなすわけないですよそこでと小太刀
考えました
管理に4野党
[音楽]
という意味でこの3億円の豪邸の母人は
こちらの方ですどうぞ
ああああああ
pal
[音楽]
味気ないかじゃあようこそ第37校だけの
動画たまにでっていうこと言ってください
はいフォルダと仕事が少ないどうですこの
うち
いやをすごいですよ一般のいいじゃない
ですよねこれはもうビールですねビデスロ
いるですよなんかお家だと思ってたら思っ
た以上に知ってるしっかりしててもう住居
というかも本当あのビール会社とかが入る
ようなテナントが揃うようなビルダーな
設計されてて管理ができるということで
大地くんが前職でちょっと不動産とか別途
ねそうです不動産やってました応神
ジャックパーセル
まあ1以上
ブーブー今の家のそのはじめキャプチャー
佐藤家に来る人がいいなくて客にこの
タイミングで戻ってきてくれたのは奇跡な
んじゃないかといいタイミングなんじゃ
ないかということで
ちょっと台作るこの家のハイ管理にを剥い
任命いたしますはい
はーいよろしくお願いますどうください
今度いない何体かここに一人で来てるん
ですけどなんだろもう一人でいると勝ち組
になった気分ん
いやこの
これは
奥番長だっているそういう台が作るのもお
嫁です
ほっ食べる
嫁ほしくない
群馬なんかすごいいいだからこそやらない
といけないことが多いというあとちょっと
を去りすぎるねさあ
をさについて照明が暗かったりするんです
よね僕結局どうだとるの大前提でこのを
誓っているんでしょうメートルを全部変え
たりいえば防犯的にもセキュリティを守っ
てあげようと思ってと一新しろーとしたり
しててこの国も引っ越しも含めてかなり
までやることがあるのでどうですか年代に
擦れる同格だよちょっと木日ギリギリかな
っていう年内お願いしますわかります
ずっとほんとねさてせると思ってるんです
けどやっぱ賃貸の違ってねおー市岡うって
いうことは相当自分でやらなきゃいけない
ことだってホント無理なんて僕一人とか
だったら本当にそれ専門の人が1人いない
となりたいならないと思ってるんでちょっ
ちかってーとこっちがしばらくメインなん
ですよねそうだねもう意識があるというで
自分でできないかないろんな人へ方ので
業者さんとかそれも時間かかるしもそうだ
ねー
[音楽]
あと呼び戻すよちょっと本当に僕だった
できないことを大地くんに知識もつけて
戻ってきてくれたということで千葉り
こっちをお願いしたいと思いますお任せ
くださいだけで第一かの役職は畑というか
巾木にも頭に出ますけど一つは
竿軒の豪邸の限り入っ
そしてもう一つが張った芸の魂に出演
そしてもう一つ肇社長の道の mime
support
はいこの3つをお仕事サフ
あっ
[音楽]
はーるへ
行っ
は